attention all wireless device users did
you know that your beloved mouse or
keyboard can be hacked in seconds using
a mouse Jack Attack through the wireless
radio signal of your device hackers get
access to all of your personal
information oops
that's because often manufacturers do
not develop their devices from scratch
but use certain chips with an insecure
wireless radio interface and one of them
is the nrf24l chip Dell Logitech
Microsoft HP Amazon gigabyte and Lenovo
all use that chip so how do you protect
yourself simple use a wired connection
device that has no such vulnerability or
a Bluetooth device and you can check if
your device is vulnerable here see how a
mouse Jack Attack can be performed with
the help of a drone in our video all
links in the comments protect yourself
now before it's too late